dmt and 5mo dmt these these create this
religious experience this connection
people describe them as a strong
connection to god
in theory these are accessible with with
modern methods we we now that we have
these rich recording methods we we can
explore what are the
precise
millisecond resolution cellular
resolution
brainwide
manifestations of these altered states
so like you could uh look at an altered
state like an on dmt
record it across many people
and then from there see where do these
experiences originate in the brain in
terms of single neurons and then
uh how do they how do they propagate and
interact with everything else and if
there's some kind of
uh common
signal like how do you
narrow down the set of neurons that are
responsible for particular experience or
for a particular behavioral effect yeah
here's where optogenetics is so useful
because any time you give an agent like
a you know an agent like
ketamine or pcp which we used for our
dissociation experiments that i was
mentioning or you have a psychedelic
lsd or dmt
for this
altered perceptual state
if you
if you give either of those these
change everything across the brain okay
so just just the fact that you maybe
give them to a mouse let's say or
eventually to a human
you won't know
yet
which cells to hone in on as the causal
players in all this just by recording
the activity
but then
what we found is that optogenetics
providing a causal pattern of activity
guided
by what you see
can let you test hypotheses and we saw
this rhythm
with ketamine and pcp for dissociation
and then we said okay
let's test what's causal
we came in and provided that rhythm we
tried a few different things but only
one of the causal tests we tried
actually caused the behavioral
dissociation
and so that's how we home in on what
actually means and is it repeatable once
you see the cause so like that's one
definition of causality is like you try
and repeats across different mice and
all that kind of stuff exactly
and so you could do that for dmt you
could do that for like the really
fascinating mind expanding uh uh
thank you so thank you so the meme for
people just listening this is again
another disagreement between freud and
and uh
carl jung religion and spirituality this
is the i guess the ring scene from uh
lord of the rings religion spirituality
freud says cast it into the fire destroy
it
carl jung says
no so so for people who don't know
sergey is
the slavic lord of the meme thank you i
appreciate that
so what we're talking about so do there
is i mean i think a connection between
gmt and religious experiences or some of
these psychedelics do you think it's
possible to
sort of stimulate religious experiences
so religious experiences are one of the
most
deep kind of experiences and so here you
could
first understand
where they originate how they propagate
to the brain
and then to stimulate them yeah
and so this is and these that can happen
in
people who had no predisposition um
you know people who who are
you know as agnostic or atheistic as
you'd like they can have these they can
feel connected to god in these in these
states
now to be clear i'm not advocating these
we don't know what's safe in human
beings but we definitely got not yet but
we definitely can do these experiments
in in mice and that was already
very productive in understanding
dissociation so we can already imagine
making headway on these methods
you